Donald Trump has repeated the worst
thing he has done in this campaign worse
than the spearing of african-americans
or the self-congratulations over the
Orlando nightclub shooting or even the
display of madness as he petulantly
backed away from the lifeblood of his
campaign birtherism worse than all that
worse than anything any other candidate
for president has done in our history
and it is the second time he has done it
and after he did it he reminded
everybody he did it on Twitter and yet
you may have already forgotten it
because within 24 hours with the
atrocity of his message already in the
ears of those to whom it was music
Donald Trump did what he always does to
prevent getting called in by the
grown-ups he changed the subject he did
something else he shot off his big bazoo
about another topic in this case about
the terrorism here in New York and
suddenly he got us yelling at him as he
always does over something not quite as
bad as what he had said the day before
Trump you again dog whistled for
somebody to assassinate your opponent
you did it in a speech in Miami then you
went back to a hotel and obsessed over
what they were saying about you online
like you were a 14-year old like you do
every night and every morning and there
wasn't enough praise for the omniscient
omnipotent Trump nosov you're being so
you dog whistled again on Twitter what
kind of sick bastard
are you Trump again predicating this on
another one of your lies that Hillary
Clinton wants to eliminate the Second
Amendment I wish as if somebody could
you said I think that her bodyguards
should drop all weapons they should
disarm I think they should disarm
immediately what do you think yes take
their guns away
she doesn't want guns take them let's
see what happens to her take their guns
away okay it will be very dangerous
Trump what do you think those idiots out
there think you meant it'll be dangerous
Trump because the Secret Service
dropping it weapons will damage the
floor somewhere it'll be dangerous
because without guns the Secret Service
wouldn't be able to protect the crowds
from escaped circus animals
the people who heard you say take their
guns away let's see what happens we'll
think you meant somebody should shoot
her see what she thinks of gun control
then and they will think that Trump
because that's what you meant because
that's also what you meant when you said
it in North Carolina in August
if she gets to pick her judges nothing
you can do folks
although the Second Amendment people
maybe there is I don't know you meant
shoot her
you meant kill her you meant assassinate
her and even when the former director of
the CIA said that anybody else who said
what you said would quote be in the back
of a police wagon now with the Secret
Service questioning him you went back
and you did it again one month later
Trump you don't know this because it's
not on Twitter at the moment but the
theme of this country's political
history is not greatness nor grouse nor
compromise it is assassination President
Reagan shot survived President Ford two
attempts to shoot him in a span of 17
days not injured President Andrew
Jackson shot at point-blank both guns
misfired
President Truman saved from being shot
by White House police President Nixon
gunman Arthur Bremer's plans were foiled
by the Secret Service so he shot George
Wallace instead a month later President
Franklin Roosevelt shot at three weeks
before his inauguration gunmen miss
killed the mayor of Chicago President
Theodore Roosevelt shot while
campaigning to regain the White House
President Taft gunman apprehended along
his parade route President Clinton
gunman shot 29 times towards the White
House presumably thinking a man he saw
in the long was the president President
Lincoln shot dead President Garfield
shot dead President McKinley shot dead
President Kennedy shot dead 13 of our
presidents Trump 13 of our presidents
30% nearly one in three shot and killed
were shot and injured or shot at and
missed or about to be shot at and you
three times in two months you dog
whistle to the word
dregg's of this gun craze Death Wish
Society that the Second Amendment people
should do something that guns be taken
from her heavily armed Secret Service
detail that we should see what happens
to her when eight years ago Hillary
Clinton merely mentioned that she had
not ended her Democratic nomination bid
yet because a previous Democratic
frontrunner like Bobby Kennedy had been
assassinated
she was excoriated for that she was
shunned i shun her it remains her low
point and she apologized within hours
the same day Trump and she never dog
whistled for somebody to shoot her
opponent as you did and she didn't just
change the subject to something else she
didn't do what you did enraged as you
were that you had to admit to your lie
about birtherism you went out and
brought up assassination the same night
to wish to incite to dog whistle to do
anything but repudiate and fight against
physical violence against the political
leader in this country is beyond
despicable with our history with our
political analyst stained with the blood
of everybody from Martin Luther King to
Ronald Reagan to Harvey Milk and I pity
you Trump that you have so little of
humanity or decency inside you that you
could so cravenly and dismissively say
it let's see what happens to her but I
know what should happen to you Trump
that ex-cia director General Michael
Hayden was right August 9th after you
did this the first time because of quote
the prevalence of political
assassination inside of American history
and how that is a topic that we don't
ever come close to even when we think
we're trying to be light-hearted if
someone else had said that outside the
hall he'd be in the back of a police
wagon now with the Secret Service
questioning him you made a call for
violence against the other candidate for
president Trump less than three months
before the election then you repeated it
two times once on social media and the
Secret Service should now take general
Hayden's cue
and you Trump you should be in the back
of a police wagon now being questioned
and then you know what let's see what
happens
that's the closer I'm Keith Olbermann
watch this space